[Musik]
natürlich bin ich bauer um die welt zu
ernähren wir leisten einen kleinen
anteil daran
mein name ist axel dettweiler ich bin 45
jahre alt wohne hier in wintersheim auf
dem petershof
das wohnhaus in dem wir leben dürfen ist
400 jahre alt der betrieb wurde erstmals
von der familie dettweiler gepachtet
mitte des achtzehnten jahrhunderts
vorfahren von mir haben dann in betrieb
immer weiter entwickelt hatten früher in
den 1960 er jahren schweine hatten kühe
hatten diverse feldfrüchte hat weinbau
mittlerweile ist der betrieb ohne tiere
wir haben jetzt rein ackerbaubetrieb
[Musik]
ich bin hier auf dem
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb groß
geworden da war lag auch immer nahe
diesen betrieb weiterzuführen was in
meiner jugend aber gar nicht so in
meinem fokus stand bin heutzutage aber
eigentlich ganz froh dass ich den
betrieben mache oder machen darf
[Musik]
ich sehe in summe meine familie mich mal
weniger als viele andere arbeitnehmer
was aber der vorteil ist dadurch dass
ich hier auf dem hof arbeite und wohne
und auch mein büro auf dem hof hat sehe
ich immer wenn die kinder in den
kindergarten gehen wenn sie von der
schule zurück kommen
wir schaffen es häufig die mahlzeit mit
den kindern einzunehmen wir sitzen
zusammen am tisch das ich als sehr
großes privileg haben sie hier
[Musik]
ich bin selbstständig kann mir viele
dinge die meine neigung sprechen
aussuchen und habe eigentlich die
letzten 15 jahre mir meinen
arbeitsalltag so gestrickt dass er mir
sehr viel freude bereitet und dass ich
da auch meinen erfolg drin sehe und dass
ich da auch die nächsten 25 jahre noch
weiter bestreiten möchte
[Musik]